hubo intensos combates en jartum el
miércoles por la mañana a pesar de una
tregua de 24 horas que comenzó a última
hora del martes el cuartel general del
ejército en la capital sudanesa estaba
en llamas las explosiones y los tiroteos
continuaron durante la noche estas
personas y aventuraron a salir para
tratar de comprar comida en una
panadería que estaba abierta con el
conflicto entrando en su quinto día
la gente decía que habría un alto el
fuego eso no ha sucedido al contrario
los combates sean intensificado
las fotografías tomadas por satélite
mostraban incendios en dos zonas de
jartum El martes por la tarde así como
aviones destruidos en varias bases
militares incluida la estratégica base
de merobue a unos 330 kilómetros al
norte de la capital el sábado pasado
estallaron combates entre las fuerzas de
dos generales que tomaron el poder en un
golpe de estado en 2021 el jefe del
ejército del fatal borjan y su adjunto
Mohamed hande conoci do como geometti
que comanda las paramilitares fuerzas de
apoyo rápido se acusó al mutuamente De
no respetar La tregua los combates
continúan con millones de civiles
atrapados la ONU dice que los
trabajadores de las misiones de ayuda
humanitaria y sus instalaciones están
siendo atacadas